oh this is Mortal Kombat if you don't
know what that is then you don't deserve
to get a tattoo okay greatest game ever
made and I haven't added my body to show
you that I'm not to be messed around
with when it comes to more combat hey
what happens EQ Trevor Jackson here and
I'm gonna show you guys some of my
tattoos alright take that
I was 18 I got my first tattoo I think I
was telling my mom was like y'all I'm
gonna get it I know you don't want it
but sorry that's like the first thing I
got I think when I turned 18 it's
actually in her handwriting so I made it
easier it's the first Bible verse I ever
learned my grandma taught it to me
second Timothy 1:7 forgot it's not
giving us the spirit of fear but of
power and of love and of a sound mind so
that kind of made it easier for her to
take in so go to my handwriting it's
about God's hands good the rest of them
she doesn't run away and I got my left
back in my whole left arm but I want to
get the left leg and then like this side
balance I think that's the universal law
so that's kind of what I want to
represent BAM this is one love most of
my family lives in Marion Indiana and my
uncle his name's uncle squeak he's 300
pounds super big guy the most gentle
pure soul you ever meet and every time
he sees this he's always like one love
nephew one love so all our family would
always say and then me but cousin
Randall my cousin were Sean we went to
this guy's garage
I've regret this tattoo artists honest
leaves a little scary okay I was like
let's do it you know my cousin he knows
I did it so I know the guys like all
right cool we go there definitely won't
be going back i had a phase where i was
doing like one like every every other
week all of my tattoos have extreme
meaning like i never just get something
kind of random it's always like specific
to it either situation that happened or
a value of mine that i have or a belief
i got this one which is cop widow it's
an african Brazilian martial art the
African slaves are brought to Brazil
they weren't allowed to train martial
arts so they disguised it as a dance
I've been training that that saw me
discipline acrobats music a lot of good
values in there oh this is Mortal Kombat
if you don't know what that is then me
on desire to get a tattoo okay
greatest game ever made and I'm very
very good at it and I haven't added my
body to show you that I'm
to be mr. Allen when it comes more
combat on this side you got Toy Story
these are the alien from Toy Story
they're pointing at what the claw now
are the reason why I got this on my vice
is I feel like humans right we put on
this earth and out of this you know
we're trying to figure out why we're
here we don't know why we're here but a
lot of us feel like we're meant to do
something and I feel like that's what I
li ins were in that movie they were just
in this glass cage they didn't know
what's going on but they always like to
something else they want it to be more
to ascend you know I mean don't stay
stationary life is boring like that so
right here I got prints it's hard to
like kill our boy he was somebody who I
really saw and started venturing out and
being true to myself writing my own
music playing guitar I picked up a
guitar cos him and I've just really
started being the captain of my own ship
and then right here the man come on now
my dad when I was younger forced me to
like watch all these martial movies
obviously Bruce Lee was like the main
attraction of those movies and just what
he stood for man he's another one that
was like okay you guys want me to be
like this but I'm gonna do my way and
create a new thing I feel like him and
Muhammad Ali are two people that even
before they were great they would always
say they were great and it's that belief
in yourself that kind of you need in
order to be great
[Music]
it's an ambigram
check it out Jackson this way and then I
flip it like that yeah Jackson both ways
and then up here the man of the hour
Silver Surfer greatest superhero of all
time he's my favorite superhero he gave
up his life to save his world and he has
the power of the cosmos everybody asked
me wouldn't you get a tattoo I say get
it when you feel like it
you know there's no particular time it's
just whenever you feel like you doing it
that's when you're supposed to do it me
my dad had matching tattoos
like father like son so it's like a big
lion and then there's like a baby lion
on the inside of it one of my favorite
tattoos I was going through something
crazy and turned out way better than it
could have could have been very bad and
that's felt like I was saved so I have a
picture of Jesus pulling Peter out the
water on my back and then there's like a
boat over here that one hurt three
sessions man had to drink a lot in order
to get it down yeah I've seen a lot of
people with sick sick testes that's the
beauty of it too is like it's known one
person like home just randomly find
somebody like yo do you have a number
for would you get that picture or I'll
take a picture of them doing the other
tattooers can have something similar to
this okay so this is a French story so I
went to like this massage thing in this
lady she kept saying like the whole time
you have like this lady on your left
side this woman I don't know if it's an
old wife or an old grandma or somebody
that has always been guiding you on your
left side but the funny thing was that's
where I got my first tattoo of my
grandma's you know Bible versions my
mom's handwriting so anyway I was at the
tattoo shop and then I looked in the
trash and I saw that I was like who was
that and he's like I was just a tattoo I
did before I was like that lady though I
don't know she is never seen him before
but she looks dope so as I did you do
that so he did that on the back of my
arm and then within that I have the
yin-yang sign because of the balance
thing and then my favorite number is
eight so in her earring it's an eight in
the new yang yang sign and then I have
seven seven seven in our hat which is
like my favorite sevens like one more
numbers and three sevens it's always
kind of a period in my life I'm gonna
get flash right here and then I'm gonna
get all the Ninja Turtles right here and
then I haven't figured out this area yet
my next one I'm gonna get probably is
rough drafts which is the name of my
album rubber jazz part one so I'm
probably to get that maybe here cuz
rough drafts I feel like has been the
the theme of my life of like the past
few years you don't have to be perfect
in all of the mistakes sometimes you're
lost in life are so essential to who
you're gonna be in the future and that's
kind of like what the tattoos
represented me too it's like where I was
in life I'm proud you know whether I was
lost whether I was sad whether it was
happy I'm proud that I got through it
and you know I'm gonna continue on super
sick I was had a picture of it so I
could show you but when I get it I'll
post a picture on Instagram
hey tattoo hey guys thanks for checking
out my tattoos and I will be coming back
to show you the new additions hopefully
I have two whole side done by then a lot
of paying a lot of hours but I'm willing
to put put in the work